la chance de le connaître tout petit
parce que son agent de l'époque c'était
le même que chez nous on va en perdre
votre grand père au bar applique donc
alors il longtemps alors oui on a lâché
2,18 si on entend par yves montand et à
l'âge de 12 ans donc je les rencontrais
et c'est vrai que j'ai été le voir en
concert au palais des sports pour
inspecter mad max salle où les vignes
tout bête sur man gens prenaient feu sur
scène bon et moi on m'a emmené dans sa
loge et dont je rends tu t'es vu quand
même pas très grand et là il se retourne
et avec une peau de bête mais lui ne
trouille j'étais super héros pêcheurs
il ne s'est jamais assez que c'est chez
gangstarr là il n'oublie jamais et moi
il m'a montré que j'étais petit il m'a
payée il m'appelait benji et j'ai revu
des années plus tard en arrivant à tf1
pour présenter un concert je rentre dans
sa loge et il était en slip
l'acheteur a pesé mais parce que c'est
quand même c'est quand même johnny et
lino d'envahir entre il dit bonjour
benji sa maus libre oui en slip et comme
l'a raconté et julien il commence à me
parler où il était pas super en forme ça
l'emmerdé un plomb était à rouen pour un
spectacle aidera et puis je dis quand
même dire qu'il n'a pas l'air très en
forme et je peux vous dire que dix
minutes avant le spectacle se changer
son ami lumière et le mec c'est un faux
il se transforme la cera cieux il hilare
et de réformes relatives à ce mec n'est
pas comme nous c'est johnny hallyday est
un dieu